well let's crack straight on shall we we
start this morning with the leveling up
secretary and it's more than five and a
half years since the grenful tower fire
that killed 72 people and Michael gave
this morning says the government is
partially to blame for the disaster
because of poor guidance on buildings I
spoke to Michael gave just a few moments
ago
thank you so much for being on the
program this morning I think it's quite
refreshing to actually start with policy
after the last few weeks but I did want
to talk to you about policy we all
remember the absolute tragedy of the
gramful fire six years on it feels like
you're finally doing something on unsafe
cladding what is the plan well we're
making clear to developers that we've
got a new contract that they've got to
sign so the people who were responsible
for erecting buildings which we now know
are unsafe have to pay the costs of
making sure that those buildings are
safe we've been trying to to deal with
this problem as you quite rightly say
for a number of years and they've been
well-intentioned efforts actually by
lots of people but the knob of it is
that until recently the leaseholders the
people actually in the flats were being
asked to consider paying for some of the
costs for things that they were not
responsible for so that should end now
that we're publishing this contract and
seeing developers and to be fair they
they accept the responsibility should
pay up at Skies City editor Mark
Kleinman reported this week that you're
close to signing this legally blinding
deal to fix unsafe buildings so when do
you hope it's going to be signed and how
much could it cost the industry well
we're going to publish it tomorrow and
we are going to give uh every developer
sort of Windows six weeks during which
we hope they will sign some have already
indicated that they will I mean I don't
want to preempt you know there's a bit
of a speculation about some of the
developers who will but all the
indications are uh that the overwhelming
majority will and those who don't will
face consequences if they don't sign the
contract uh we'll make sure that in
effect they won't be able to build
anything more in the future
um and uh yeah we we think it will be in
the in the realm of billions that we
will be able to unlock in order to deal
with this crisis in the region of five
billion is that right yes
um you know I just want to talk you say
that they've been well-intentioned
efforts before
the same time you know grenful happened
six years ago we all remember you know
the the horrific images of those people
trapped inside the building and only
seven percent of 368 000 dangerous Flats
have been fixed yes it's not good enough
I mean the intentions might be good but
that's that's not gonna happen no no I I
completely agree I'm I am the first I
hope to acknowledge that we haven't done
right by uh the the bereaved and the
residents and the survivors in grenful
and that is one very very important
Mission but it's also the case that
there have been people who have been
effectively imprisoned in their own fats
for too long uh as we know after
grenfell
um there were hundreds of buildings that
were identified as having similar faults
to grenful not identical but similar
um and uh we knew that all of the people
who were in those buildings uh not only
were they not safe but it was also the
case entirely understandably that they
could move because they couldn't sell
their flat they couldn't get a mortgage
you know from an economic point of view
the market was Frozen but from a human
point of view far more importantly
people's lives were were completely
disrupted so again
um I haven't always will apologize to
people for the fact that it's taken this
long to sort but now we have got
progress do you also take some
responsibility on behalf of the
government for what happened at
Granville I think that if you look at
what happened to Grenville there were
lots of factors but yes government
collectively has to take some
responsibility now I think that the
responsibility extends before the
conservatives came into government in in
um and I'm I'm not about attributing
blame to individuals I think that's
wrong because uh there are a lot of us
who have a responsibility to say that
the system of Regulation that was in
place was ambiguous and it was exploited
by people who were putting profit before
lives and and again you know there's
there is I think and I hope this doesn't
seem so on dodging responsibility I
don't want to at all I think there's a
difference between presiding over a
system that's negligent and actively
exploiting it but it is undeniably the
case that the system of building
regulation was not right would you
apologize to those families I absolutely
would and uh again I've had the uh
the chance to talk to many of the
families most directly affected since
doing this job I
um brought up my children just quite
close to uh to Granville and I remember
visiting aside just a couple of days
after the the fire and thinking that it
was horrific that this had happened the
more that I discovered about uh the
circumstances they're the more horrified
I was there were people in that building
who had warned beforehand uh that they
were in potential danger the warnings
were not heated
um and the inquiry which followed and uh
Theresa May was absolutely right to set
it up because it it's it's shown a light
on terrible practice it exposed the fact
that there were a variety of different
people from the people who manufactured
the cladding to the people who applied
it who just didn't do the right thing
and I have one more question on housing
before we move on to other issues
someone who should we says has
experienced the peculiarities of the
leasehold system I was quite struck by
your interview with the Sunday Times
where you said you wanted to abolish it
yes are you hoping for that to happen
before the election yes we want to
introduce legislation in the the final
parliamentary session so later this
calendar year in order to change the
leasehold system it's not easy in legal
terms because you know when you've got a
tangle of property laws going back
hundreds of years unstitching all of
that is difficult but the fundamental
thing is that leasehold is just a it's
an unfair form of property ownership uh
you know in crude terms if you buy a
flat that should be yours you shouldn't
be on the hook for charges which uh
managing agents and other people can
land you with which are you know gouging
um another story that I'm Keen to find
out more about this morning is given the
state of the ambulance waiting times is
that tomorrow you're announcing a plan
to treat half a million patients in what
you're calling hospitals at home yeah
what's that idea well the the principle
there is to make sure that we can
provide people with the quality of care
that they might enjoy in hospital in
their home and there are at least three
benefits from that the first is that
there are many people I know personally
who would rather have a relative at home
uh if they're ill and if they can get
the care required and this comes to the
second point if you can make sure that
there are uh visits by nurses or by
other clinical professionals who can
make sure that someone is comfortable
and looked after effectively then the
third thing is that you can also free up
capacity in hospitals themselves for uh
the more acute cases that require more
specific intervention let's you know get
to the number of what this is right you
know hospitals at home
it's not really hospital it's your home
right that's it feels like a quite a
nice kind of way of putting it but
you're effectively being treated at home
because our hospitals are full yes the
average ambulance wait time for a heart
attack 93 minutes in December 55 000
people waiting on trolleys more than 12
hours in a e you're being forced to do
this and you have some nice phrase for
your hospitals at home because there
aren't enough beds well again one of the
reasons why we need to do it is that
there are people who are in hospital who
need care but who can be cared for
effectively at home um you know again in
hospitals we all know there are
intensive care units there are other
facilities that do require uh the the
individual to have the the the the range
of interventions that can only be
delivered in hospital but there are
other things that can be done uh there
are drugs that can be administered there
are treatments that can be monitored um
and provided someone is uh safe and warm
at home then that care can be
administered there and again uh when the
Prime Minister organized a health Summit
a few weeks ago uh one of the the
Striking things that uh that came out of
that and and which many of us knew
beforehand was that if you can have the
the right bespoke package of care then
someone can be more comfortable and uh
easily as well cared for as a hospital
but it depends on the type of patient it
depends on the type of condition of
course let's
start the other Sunday on the front page
of the Sunday Times uh shall we and this
is the story about Boris Johnson and his
relationship with Richard Sharp who is
now of course the BBC chairman and
whether or not Richard Sharp helped to
guarantee or find someone to guarantee
an 800 000 pound loan well according to
the Sunday Times Boris Johnson was
formally told to stop asking Mr Sharp
for advice about his Affairs days before
he was announced as a government's
choice for BBC chairman this is the
letter the advice from the cabinet
office according to the Sunday Times
given the imminent announcement of
Richard Sharp As the new BBC chair it's
important that you no longer ask his
advice about your personal financial
matters and I just want to compare that
to what Boris Johnson told Sky News last
week when he said Bishop sharp knows
absolutely nothing about my personal
finances I can tell you that for ding
dang it sure I mean how can that
possibly be true well I think again I
only don't know about the conversations
that that we're carrying on
um well the only two things I would say
the one thing is that I know that uh and
I've seen it happen in the past that
there are uh there's a letter here a
note there a comment there it points
towards one conclusion once you know all
the evidence actually another conclusion
can fairly be drawn though you know if
he was given a letter by the Simon Case
by the cabinet so secretary saying stop
asking him for advice about your
personal finances he can't say oh he
knew nothing about my personal finances
for Ding Dang sure I mean these two
things seem completely contradictory
well again I would say that I don't know
all the details and I must recognize
that as well no I I completely recognize
how you can produce two pieces of
evidence and and and a conclusion can be
drawn but I know hard to draw another
conclusion well I know from uh
experience in the past including when I
jump to conclusions about people and
then found that actually I've been
unfair on them that we just need to see
all the facts and it is the case that
the manner of Richard Sharp's
appointment is being looked at by the
commissioner for public appointments
just to make sure that everything was
completely kosher um and so again you
know it's it's
absolutely understandable uh to think
aha this plus this equals that but my my
bitter experience is wait until you see
all the facts before coming to a
definitive conclusion okay we will wait
to see the facts is poorest Johnson
becoming a liability no
um I think Boris Johnson
um was a a very good prime minister and
I think that he has a lot to contribute
to public life in the future okay um
Nadim zahawi another investigation going
on of course into whether Nadine zahawi
broke the ministerial code over his tax
Affairs can you tell us when we should
expect that report is it next week
I don't know I know that Solario Magnus
is the independent advisor on these
issues who's having a look at it
um once the conclude his investigation
as quickly as possible and I think in
fact I know that Nadine wants the
investigation to be concluded as quickly
as possible so uh I've spoken about to
him about it
um I I know that Nadeem wants the thing
done with
um I I haven't spoken to Laurie Magnus I
wouldn't uh so but I I don't know uh and
and again I think it's in everyone's
interests that the matter is concluded
as quickly as possible uh but it's also
the case that when you've got someone
specifically appointed to be independent
then me providing a running commentary
on on the timings one could be
misconstrued understood if if he's found
to have broken the ministerial code
should he lose his job well again it's
the serious thing to break the
ministerial code but again it's up to
the prime minister in possession of the
full facts I I know it's irritating when
politicians say oh we've got to wait for
the the result of the inquiry but once
you've set it up once you've got this um
uh independent person looking at all the
evidence I think
trying to
anticipate yes what he concludes and
therefore what follows what well you
know I completely understand that you
know it smells dry said
melstar says it would be a difficult
finding you say it would be a serious
thing I mean it would be difficult
wouldn't it again you know I I I suspect
that we'll find out soon enough and then
a judgment can be made on that basis
understood now unsurprisingly all of
this we've been talking about the NHS
we've been talking about the financial
allegations that are being investigated
is having an impact on people's view of
the conservative party we had a surprise
guest in calling into our NHS phone in
this week I just want to play what
happened this is Rod Stewart calling in
to Sky News
I personally have been a touring for a
long time but I think this government
should stand down now and give the labor
party a go at it because this is
heartbreaking for the nurses it really
is heartbreaking in all my years of
living in this country I've never seen
it so bad
I feel like he's articulating what a lot
of your former voters are thinking well
uh I grew up listening towards you I'm a
huge fan of his um and uh all I would
say is that the government is absolutely
focused on solving the problems that rod
and others are worried about we're
absolutely focused on making sure that
we can cut waiting lists we're
absolutely determined to ensure that we
can uh uh half inflation that we can uh
reduce debt that we can grow the economy
and also that we can deal with the uh
illegal immigration problems stopping
the boats in the channel those
priorities are absolutely essential to
the government and of course there are
people uh like sarod and others who are
natural conservatives who have concerns
at the moment our job is to convince
them that on inflation on growth on
reducing debt on making sure that we cut
waiting lists and stop the boats that we
are delivering you see you know I don't
think anyone would dispute the British
United's had a difficult hand to play
right you came off the back of Liz
truss's disastrous budget we've had a
backdrop of high inflation the
conservatives and power for over a
decade but the poles are moving in the
wrong direction I think we can have a
quick look this is a kind of yougov
tracker poll and you can see that there
hasn't actually been a bounce the polls
are moving in the wrong direction the
the Gap is still wide and if you look at
the leader approval ratings as well uh
when you compare Rishi sunak to Kirsten
you can see that right at the end Chris
Thomas red line is going up and Rishi
sunax is dropping you know if you're
conservative and P going to be looking
at this you can be really worried well
again polls are snapshots um this isn't
a snapshot this is over time that's why
I chose it rather than a snapshot uh
evidence would suggest that over the
course of the last few years it's very
difficult to say how politics is going
to look in a year or an 18 months time
so again the you know the the uh the
evidence there shows they their
volatility actually of public opinion on
a variety of areas in the way in which
reputations can rise and fall
um but volatile there's been a very
significant lead for the labor party for
some time now uh and as there has been
for opposition parties during periods
when governments have been empowered
during the middle of their term in
office the critical thing though is
um people want to see a government that
is making an impact all of us can be
commentators and can be invited to offer
a gloss on the polls but the difference
is that my job
my loss of the pause is no is no better
than anyone else's my job is to deliver
that's it though isn't it you said that
people want governments who are making
an impact yes you are a reformer right
you know you go into departments you're
not worried about breaking a few eggs
you look at Rishi CNAC you look at
Jeremy Hunter Chancellor
are they a bit timid no God no no no no
no I mean the the nigerial no well well
the the the thing is that um being an
effective manager of public money and
public services is not a sin in my view
but it is the case but first of all we
had to bring a stability and we have and
now we've set out areas where we are
reforming so Jeremy gave a fantastic
speech on Friday in which he explained
how it is that we can make the country
uh essentially the technological
Powerhouse of The Next Century how by
improving education having a culture of
Entrepreneurship making sure that we get
more people back into employment and
making sure that we have investment
everywhere across the country to level
up we can drive economic reform let's
talk about education shall we teachers
are striking next week
sorry are they right to you no
um my own son's school is going to be
affected by this I do sympathize with
the position that many teachers are in
but I would ask them respectfully not to
go on strike because I believe as the
education sector is do you think Keegan
has said you know you don't need to go
on strike to get her attention she cares
about improving because that's the whole
point isn't it teachers feel like it is
the only way to get to get people's
attention if you look at the ifs they
say that most teachers will see it five
percent real terms pay cut this year and
that's on the back of successive real
terms pay cuts over the last decade
we've got a recruitment crisis in
teaching it is no surprise it's no
Comfort to anyone to point out how
difficult economic circumstances over
are overall and that is why it is so
important and it's our top priority to
reduce inflation that is the best tax
cut the best pay rise that anyone that's
penalized that people could get is an
actual pay rise that would only
contribute to further inflation in the
future it would only create a spine I
thought it was a global inflation crisis
now you're saying teachers are to blame
for it no I'm not saying that teachers
to blame for an inflation crisis not at
all but I am saying that all of us have
a responsibility to recognize that when
public money is tight when we need to
reduce inflation when we need to get
that down we also need to make sure that
um pay Awards reflect that on on the
recruitment issue in teaching as well of
course pay is a factor but it's also the
case that we need to support teachers by
providing them with the right tools to
have effective discipline and behavior
in the classroom the other thing is that
at the overwhelming majority of teachers
go into teaching because they're
idealistic they want to transform the
opportunities of the next generation of
children so again making sure that we do
the right thing in education overall by
providing teachers with the tools to uh
deliver the curriculum effectively is
also important what would be a realistic
pay raise a fair pay rise for teachers
again um it's not for me to say but I
think the important thing is that uh the
the
program of conversations that teachers
and teaching unions are having with the
education secretary which I know the
education sector is committed to and
she's a warm and open person that is the
best route to a conclusion just finally
when you education secretary I remember
there was a lot of talk about what was
termed as the blob people who were
resistant to your reforms are these
strikes an example of The Blob in action
no
thank you very much Michael gave good to
have in the program thank you very much
Sophie thank you